[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINKO GECHEV: Hello, everyone.
My name is Minko Gechev.
I lead developer relations
for Angular at Google.
Today I will share with you
how to host a Modern Angular
application with
Google Cloud platform.
We can render a single-page
application implemented
in Angular or any other
frontend framework
in three different ways.
Client-side rendering, where the
browser receives an index HTML
file with reference scripts.
Once the scripts load, they
render the application.
Prerendering, or
static site generation,
is where at build time, we
render an HTML file per route.
While the browser loads
the HTML file for a route,
it renders it and loads
the reference JavaScript.
The page becomes
interactive once the browser
executes all the JavaScript.
Finally, there is Server-Side
Rendering, or SSR.
SSR is very similar
to prerendering,
with the main difference
being that rendering
happens at request time
by a rendering server.
Something in common between
static site generation,
or prerendering, and
client-side rendering,
is that in both cases, we only
deal with static resources.
On the other side, in
SSR, we need a server
to render the application and
produce the application's HTML
at request time.
To demonstrate the different
rendering strategies
and approaches and explore
optimal deployment,
we will use the Kitty
Cinema application.
Kitty Cinema is a
catalog of cat movies.
We can explore a list of movies
with their names, genres,
and ratings.
When we select a movie,
we can get further details
about the synopsis,
the cast, as well
to explore similar
recommended movies.
For this application, we can
use client-side rendering.
The deployment could
be pretty simple.
First, we build the application
and get its production assets.
After that, we can upload
the assets using the Firebase
tooling.
Finally, the application
will land on Firebase hosting
and be globally
available via our CDN.
Currently, we can achieve
this in a few different ways.
First, we can use the Firebase
Node.js command line tools.
We can install them
by using npm globally,
running npm i -g firebase.
After that, we can go to the
Angular CLI Workspace directory
and initialize a
Firebase project.
We can run Firebase in that.
After that choose Configure
for Firebase Hosting.
Select a project
you want to deploy,
specify a public directory--
in this case, the Angular
CLI uses the output directory
dist/movies/browser.
After that, we're
going to rewrite
all the URLs to index.html to
make sure that Angular provides
client-side routing.
We're going to disable the
deployment with GitHub.
We're not going to overwrite
index.html at this point.
Since we have already built the
application, as the next step,
just type firebase deploy
and allow the tooling
to deploy the app.
Once all the files are
in Firebase hosting,
click on the output
URL to preview the app.
An alternative approach
is using Angular CLI.
You can run ng add angular/fire
to add Firebase integration
to your project.
Select that you'd like
to set up ng deploy.
Select an account you will
want to use, and next,
select or create a new project.
After that, select
or create a new site.
And finally, just run ng deploy.
This command will build
your project and upload
the static assets
to Firebase hosting.
You can preview the result
following the output URL.
Let us track step by step
the sequence of events when
the user opens the application.
Once they enter the
URL, their browser
will send a request
to Firebase hosting
and download the
index.html that is
the page for the application.
The browser will render the
HTML and show a progress bar.
Next, the browser will download
all the reference JavaScript
within index.html.
Next, the browser will
execute the JavaScript.
Notice that at this
point, the user
still sees only a progress bar.
Until the rendering
completes, the page
will not be too useful.
At this step, Angular
will take over
and render the user
interface, making the page
useful and interactive.
For three out of the
four steps, the user
only sees a progress bar.
That's not the best
user experience.
Depending on the network
connection speed,
it may take tens of
seconds for the application
to show useful information.
In this particular
case, we don't
need to make the application
interactive immediately.
This is a content
website, which means
that even if you only
show the movie list,
the page will be still useful.
After that, we can load
the associated JavaScript
and add interactivity.
Let's explore a more
optimal deployment
strategy for the Kitty
Cinema application.
This way, we're going
to quickly serve
a useful page for the user and
later on make it interactive.
We can select a
suitable strategy
by identifying the different
types of content we can render
and taking performance
into consideration.
Ideally, we would want
to prerender everything
at build time so that we can
deploy the resources to a CDN
and deliver them from the
closest location to the user
possible.
Often, pages depend on dynamic
datastore or user session
information.
When we need to store
personalized content on a page,
it becomes infeasible to
generate it at build time.
We're going to consider
two rendering strategies.
First one is
prerendering, for pages
that don't change too often.
Serving them from a CDN will
be cheap and really fast.
We don't have to do any
work at request time,
and we can deliver
them from the closest
to the user geographical
location available.
For pages that need to
show personalized content
or depend on a very frequently
changing data source,
we can use
server-side rendering.
It's usually more technically
complicated and expensive
to serve such pages,
because at request time
we have to run the application
server, render the app,
and deliver the produced
HTML to the user.
For prerendered content, we
can use Firebase Hosting.
This is content
delivery network,
allows us to serve the
prerendered pages from a close
to the user location.
For server-side rendering,
we'll use Cloud Functions.
They provide an on-demand
execution environment
which allows us to handle
individual requests,
render our single page
application in Node.js,
and serve it to the client.
To prerender and server-side
render our application,
we're going to use
Angular Universal.
Just run in the terminal ng add
@nguniversal/express-engine,
and Angular CLI will set
everything up automatically
for you.
Earlier this year,
Google Cloud announced
Cloud Functions
Second Generation,
powered by Cloud Run.
This new version provides
more powerful infrastructure
and advanced control on
scalability and performance.
They offer longer
processing times and larger
upgraded instances, with
more memory and virtual CPUs.
To deploy our application,
we'll use Firebase SDK
for Cloud Functions, which
allows us to configure them
through code.
The Firebase SDK
allows us to only run
Node.js in the function, which
fits our goals really well.
In case you want to
use other technologies,
check out this
quick starting guide
for Cloud Functions in
Google Cloud Console.
Let us have a look at two
different pages in the app
and identify the
optimal rendering
strategy for each one of them.
We have a generic page that
shows the popular kitty movies.
We also have a page that
shows user's favorites.
The generic page could
be a good candidate
for prerendering if the popular
movies don't change too often.
If they do change
often, though, we'll
have to regenerate
the application
and redeploy it very frequently.
In such a case, we
might be better off
using server-side
rendering for it.
The page showing the
user's favorite movies
depends on the session ID, which
means that we can't generate it
at build time, and we would have
to use server-side rendering.
An approach where we use
server-side rendering
for some of the pages in the
app and prerendering for others
is called hybrid rendering.
With hybrid rendering, we can
deploy the static resources
of the application-- for
example, JavaScript images,
prerendered pages, et cetera--
to a CDN, for example
with Firebase Hosting.
The pages containing
the dynamic content
will render in Cloud Functions
with server-side rendering.
Let us look into how to deploy
an application to Firebase
Hosting that uses
hybrid rendering.
To set up hybrid rendering,
we can make a few adjustments
to firebase.json.
In this file, we can
specify a predeploy command
to our function and its source.
Here we can specify that we want
to build the Angular Universal
server before we
deploy the function.
Next we can specify the
hosting configuration.
We will set the public directory
to dist/movies/browser.
We will use cleanUrls to
strip the .html suffixes,
and also set
trailingSlash to false.
Notice that we also
add the star star
rewrites to the SSR function.
For optimal results, make
sure that you also review
the best practices for caching.
Now let us compare the
original client-side rendering
application with the
latest deployment that
uses hybrid rendering.
On the left side, you can
see the client-side rendered
application, and
on the right side,
you can see the
prerendered application.
Both are delivered from a CDN,
but the client-side rendered
application needs
to load JavaScript
before it can show any
contents to the user.
Notice how the prerendered
app loads and rendered
in half of the time needed
for the client-site rendered
alternative.
Selecting the correct
rendering strategy
can have a significant impact on
your application's performance.
All right, that's most of
what I had for you today.
Before we end, however,
I want to share one more
thing you can do
to further automate
the process of deployment
of hybrid applications using
Incremental Static Generation.
We already mentioned
in what cases we should
use prerendering
and when we should
go with server-side rendering.
In short, if a page is
user-specific or changes
very frequently,
we most certainly
want to use server-side
rendering for it.
We also discussed that we
prerender pages at build time.
Let us look into incremental
approach to prerendering.
To achieve incremental
prerendering, or static site
generation, we can use
automation via the APIs
that Firestore offers.
Let's suppose that we
store all the content
that our static pages
depend on in Firestore.
When we update the
Firestore data,
we can get a
Firestore change event
that triggers the Incremental
Static Regeneration.
Once we regenerate
pages that changed,
we can just deploy them
to Firebase Hosting.
Deploying to Firebase Hosting
purges the cache content
from the CDN, so we
will want to balance
deploying on every change
versus regenerating
static content periodically,
while still falling back
to SSR.
That's everything I
had for you today.
In this presentation,
we had a look
into different
prerendering strategies
for single-page applications
and most optimal deployment
techniques for each one of them.
For more content, make sure
you follow Angular on Twitter
and subscribe to the
Angular YouTube channel.
See you next time,
and happy coding.
[MUSIC PLAYING]